[Musique]
salut tout le monde j'espère que vous
allez bien dans cette vidéo on va parler
de la guerre en Ukraine le 24 février
2022 la Russie a décidé d'envahir le
pays et avec Camille coursy on est parti
sur place pour aller dans la capitale
qui
à ce moment là on ne savait pas du tout
combien de temps l'armée ukrainienne
allait tenir face aux troupes de
Vladimir Poutine
et on entendait quasiment toutes les
heures les sirènes d'alerte dans la
ville qui annonçaient des potentiels
attaques de l'aviation russe une guerre
c'est toujours hyper compliqué à
expliquer parce que il y a beaucoup de
propagande mais dans cette vidéo je vais
quand même essayer de vous raconter ce
qu'on a pu voir sur place et aussi vous
expliquer ce qu'on a vu passer sur les
réseaux sociaux
l'aviation russe a bombardé lourdement
de Kiev toute la nuit ça a même continué
jusqu'au petit matin là on vient
d'arriver dans un quartier ou un
immeuble a été touché par un missile à 8
heures
[Musique]
et encore de la fumée qui s'échappe du
bâtiment
de l'immeuble c'est ensuite écrasé sur
le magasin juste en dessous donc il y a
eu énormément de dégâts matériels je
vais vous montrer la rue à quoi ça
ressemble
a été extrêmement puissant parce que il
y a des débris sur plus de je dirais 200
à 300 mètres autour de l'immeuble
à cause des bombardements et des combats
dans kiffe les premiers jours des
milliers du Kenyan se réfugient dans les
sous-sols de la ville et dans des
bunkers on a pu filmer dans l'un d'entre
eux mais les soldats Ukrainiens nous ont
demandé de garder secret la localisation
du bâtiment pour des questions de
sécurité
[Musique]
ici on annonce qu'on appelle un Shelter
c'est un abri anti-bombardement très
bien protégé qui a plusieurs dizaines de
mètres de profondeur et tous les jours
il y a entre 150 et 200 personnes qui
viennent se réfugier ici
bonjour
c'est possible
[Musique]
de route
le quatrième jour de l'offensif russe la
deuxième ville du pays car qui veut
prise d'assaut mais résiste la balle et
combats sont extrêmement violents
[Musique]
avec les images de la guerre en Ukraine
les sanctions internationales se
multiplient contre la Russie face à ça
Vladimir Poutine brandi la menace ultime
il mobilise ses forces de dissuasion
nucléaire
[Musique]
la plupart des images qui arrivent des
lignes de front un peu partout dans le
pays elles sont souvent filmées par des
civils ou des militaires ukrainiens et
elle montre bien la violence des combats
avec les images des réseaux sociaux on
voit bien que les Ukrainiens se
mobilisent dans tout le pays et dans
certaines villes prises par les Russes
voire même des images de civil désarmées
qui tentent de freiner l'avancée des
chars
[Musique]
à ce moment là les centaines de milliers
du Kenya ont déjà fait le pays
mais les hommes entre 18 et 60 ans ont
l'obligation de rester pour participer à
l'effort de guerre tout le monde est
appelé à apprendre les armes les
autorités ukrainiennes distribuent des
fusils d'assaut et tente de former les
civils en seulement quelques jours pour
grossir les rangs de l'armée
là on est un endroit où les civils sont
entraînés par des militaires confirmés à
utiliser des fusils d'assaut il y en a
beaucoup qui ont déjà eu une forme
d'entraînement parce que la guerre a
commencé en 2014 mais sinon la majorité
d'entre eux n'ont jamais tenu une arme
de leur vie
[Musique]
dans ce centre d'entraînement il y avait
évidemment des profils très différents
parmi les civils on a rencontré Julia
une professeur de littérature
[Musique]
comme Julien qui ont voulu rester pour
se battre on en a croisé des dizaines
pendant notre tournage notamment dans
les quelques magasins d'équipement
encore ouverts
[Musique]
tous les Ukrainiens qui ont choisi de
rester pour se battre n'ont pas pris
forcément les armes dès le début
certains participent à l'effort de
guerre autrement
[Musique]
là je suis dans une cuisine d'un
restaurant de la capitale Kiev ou des
citoyens sont mobilisés pour préparer à
manger pour les civils qui ont pris les
armes et pour l'armée ukrainienne
prépare tout toute cette nourriture qui
part ensuite sur le front
national
c'est la participation de toute la
population à l'effort de guerre il y a
vraiment un vrai sentiment national de
il faut qu'on défende notre pays et tout
le monde participe
pourquoi c'est important pour toi ce que
tu es en train de faire là
de ce que nous faisons j'adore vivre en
Ukraine c'est mon choix moi je crois
beaucoup à l'Ukraine et au futur de
crainte de l'avenir envie par exemple de
prendre les armes
mais le truc
c'est territoire et en fait je vais
perdre juste pas mal de temps pour aller
essayer de les joindre que si je peux
faire déjà des choses tout le monde est
engagé et très motivé
ils ont des matelas des coussins
des couettes donc en fait s'ils veulent
ils peuvent rester ici dormir sur place
et vu que c'est un sous-sol ils sont
aussi protégés un peu des bombardements
ils se disent que en restant ici ils
peuvent continuer à travailler en
permanence et continuer à amener de la
nourriture sur le front
les civils qui ont pris les armes sont
postées un peu partout dans qui va des
checkpoint il contrôle tout le monde
parce que l'armée ukrainienne soupçonne
la présence d'infiltrer russe dans la
capitale
[Musique]
le 1er mars on est toujours dans keeve
avec Camille et on apprend avec cette
photo satellitaire qu'un immense qu'on
voit de charrus de plusieurs dizaines de
kilomètres se dirigent vers la capitale
[Musique]
l'armée russe en fait avance dans
plusieurs directions et les fronts se
multiplient dans tout le pays notamment
au sud particulièrement dans les villes
de Kerson et Mario Paul nous active on
entend des bombardements pas loin du
centre-ville et on apprend quelques
heures plus tard que c'est la tour de
diffusion de la télévision
ukrainienne qui a été touchée
[Applaudissements]
une partie de la structure a été
complètement calcinée à cause de
l'explosion toutes les vitres ont été
blastées par le souffle et c'est pareil
dans tous les immeubles aux alentours et
il y a un bilan humain derrière ce
bombardement il y a 5 personnes qui sont
décédées et 5 personnes qui ont été
blessées
on voit bien la puissance des missiles
russes qui ont frappé la tour et les
bâtiments autour faut savoir que c'est
toujours stratégique d'essayer de couper
les moyens de communication dans un pays
qu'on est en train d'attaquer parce que
ça permet d'empêcher le gouvernement de
communiquer des informations à la
population et ça peut aussi générer de
la panique
là en fait il y avait des civils dans
cette voiture
au moment où le missile a explosé
[Musique]
finalement la diffusion de la télévision
ukrainienne a pu reprendre seulement
quelques heures après cette attaque
[Musique]
les bombardements et les combats
continuent de s'intensifier un peu
partout dans le pays et sur les réseaux
sociaux il y a des vidéos qui sont
diffusées qui montrent l'utilisation
d'armes de guerre interdite dans
beaucoup de pays parlent les troupes
russes comme ici à tchernieves avec des
armes à soumission
les forces russes essaient d'encercler
kif des combats extrêmement violents ont
lieu dans plusieurs villes autour de la
capitale notamment à irpin qui est à
seulement quelques kilomètres au
nord-ouest de qui
[Musique]
on est en train de partir
versus se trouve là-bas et combattent
l'armée ukrainienne en ce moment
et on va essayer de se rapprocher là bas
pour filmer les civils qui sont en train
d'essayer d'évacuer cette zone
on est en train de rentrer dans no man's
land entre le dernier check night
militaire de l'armée ukrainienne et la
ligne de fond et tous les véhicules
qu'on croit sont des véhicules utilisés
pour évacuer la population de harping
donc il y a des ambulances des véhicules
privés des bus et tout le monde essaye
de sortir la population civile le plus
rapidement possible de cette zone
on est vraiment tout proche de la ligne
de combat
ce que vous entendez là c'est des
bombardements des mortiers
mais vous pouvez voir que même ici les
combats ont été violents il y a eu des
bombardements je vais vous montrer
[Musique]
24 heures plus tôt l'armée russe a
bombardé exactement à cet endroit au
moment même où des familles étaient en
train d'évacuer dire pinceau
ici c'est vraiment un point de passage
pour la population qui veut s'enfuir
vers Kiev les autorités russes le savent
pertinemment même s'il y a des
militaires Ukrainiens qui assure le
passage donc clairement il visait des
civils il voulait faire des victimes
civiles
[Musique]
à cet endroit précis qui est le lieu de
passage des véhicules pour évacuer les
gens les troupes russes n'ont pas hésité
à bombarder aussi
une fois évacué les civils arrivent au
premier de Checkpoint de chief où ils
sont pris en charge par les soldats de
l'armée urinaire
[Musique]
au même moment dans le sud de l'Ukraine
Mario Paul est dévasté par les troupes
russes
[Musique]
des quartiers entiers ont été rayés de
la carte l'hôpital de la ville a été
complètement détruit
[Musique]
S sont désormais à quelques kilomètres
de kiff et à l'intérieur de la ville les
Ukrainiens ont installé des checkpoint
un peu partout la capitale se prépare au
pire
[Musique]
voilà ce qu'on a pu filmer à kif côté
ukrainien en réalité c'est très
difficile pour le moment d'avoir des
chiffres exacts sur le nombre de
victimes de cette guerre que ce soit
côté
ukrainien ou russe et on sait déjà
qu'elle a fait des milliers de morts et
selon l'ONU environ 10 millions du Kenya
ou du fuir leur foyer dont presque la
moitié sont des enfants
[Musique]